what are the biggest mistakes you see in
screenplays over and over again I would
say that the first one is formatting I
hate when I open a script and I
immediately know you don't know how to
write you know then it comes down to you
know very passive voice and it's all is
r or Ing and things like that they're
just not moving the story forward but
then it comes you know to bigger things
you know those are just like the very
few things that you notice you know you
open it and you kind of like skim and
you're like oh they don't know how to
format they are not using you know
active tenses but then when the
characters are not fleshed out that's
one of the things I immediately see or
when the protagonist's goal doesn't
connect to the turning points where
there's no clear central conflict and
you're just kind of giving me vignettes
of scenes that are not connected and
they're not leading to something
uh I think that dialogue where all of
the characters sound the same as another
thing I see a lot and granted that's one
of the hardest things I believe for
writers is to nail dialogue and make
characters sound different because
obviously everyone talks just one way
so it's hard to kind of talk like
different people but that's an art form
that you really need to work on and
people watch you know and study the
grades and how they do it and how they
make the characters sound different and
why writing your character bio is so
important because that's where you can
figure out how they say things different
you know
um I think that those are like the
biggest things I say I'd find but then
if we go deeper into little things you
know the antagonist is not fleshed out
and they're just The Stereotype of the
bad guy or the supporting characters are
sort of Forgotten just very one note
like if you want a good script all of
those should be good fleshed out
characters especially in television
because then we'll see the characters
over time so they need rich
backstories that actors want to play
those roles I always
say it like that to you know to writers
winning even the notes I'm like all of
the supporting characters that you have
just don't have personalities like think
of the actors who are going to play
these roles you want great Supporting
Cast that it's going to bring life to it
do they want to play these roles that
they all look and sound the same
probably not so think of all of the
great supporting characters from TV
shows and try to think of ways where you
can make the best friends more
interesting for example Will and Grace
that show is a great example of making
the best friends so unique that Jack and
Karen could have almost been the
protagonist of that show because a lot
of the times they overshadowed Will and
Grace because Jack and Karen which is so
unique so layered so amazingly funny in
their own way that I think they even
make that joke one time themselves that
they could have their own show which was
like The Meta joke that they were making
in the show because they were layered
they were interesting they weren't just
the typical best friend that's just like
a sounding board for the two
protagonists you know they're rich they
are unique and that's what we want to
see in scripts and one of the things
that writers tend to forget about when
they're writing how common is it for you
to read screenplays that are too short
I think that most of the times writers
have the opposite problem and they're
just way too long especially nowadays
where I think producers obviously are
trying to cut the budgets more so I tend
to tell writers you're overwriting and
your story could be told in 90 pages and
not 120. uh I'd say that most of the
times is that I it's rare when I say you
need more pages or your story shouldn't
be you know a half hour show and should
be an hour long show I think it's the
opposite
um especially you know for example if
you're writing an animated movie that is
aimed for kids you want to Target you
know 90 Pages not 125 because no kids
gonna sit there for that long and
animation gets expensive
um but I think that when a story is too
short which does happen every now and
then it's because they haven't really
fleshed out the story enough
and because you you kind of have the
expectations in a feature you know that
they're going to reach the arc and the
goal you know that change towards the
end so you haven't fleshed that out then
that's when your story kind of like gets
cut or there's no subplots that you were
adding you just focus on your
protagonist and you forgot about your
Supporting Cast I think that that's
another thing that's very common so make
sure to include those other important
characters that it not the protagonist
but should also reflect you know the
themes of the story or what your
protagonist is going through and maybe
that can actually add to that Arc of
your protagonist what are some do's and
don'ts as it relates to World building
I think that the world needs to be
established from the very beginning and
the rules need to be clear
so one of the problems I see in Scripps
very often is when the world is not well
established and then things start
happening later on that we're not
planted so when we see them happen we
are kind of taken out of the world of
the story so for example if a magical
occurrence happens then the world needs
to be set up in a way where we know
magic Could Happen even if we don't see
you know a fairy right away but we know
that there's something that could happen
or when the world sort of
doesn't establish the rules in magical
sci-fi stories or where the rules keep
changing or are not clear enough I hate
when I'm reading you know horror and
then
it's not established exactly how things
could work and what would happen if
something doesn't work that way so you
need to pay attention to that and then
you know the world also needs to stay
sort of consistent the same thing with
genre and tone I hate when those switch
or shift halfway through this story when
you're writing a romantic comedy in act
one and that it turns into a thriller in
act two you're completely taken out of
the world of the story because it just
doesn't add up
or you know things like that where just
the world is not adding up because
things don't make sense in what you
establish in act one so act one is
really where all of this should be
established mostly in the first half of
act one which is called in my opinion
like the Ordinary World you know that
then gets disrupted by the inciting
incident that Ordinary World is where
you established all of the rules of the
world of your story where you establish
how your protagonist relates to that
world relates to the characters uh what
the rules are what we could expect to
happen in this world that's why a lot of
times horror movies start with this
little sort of teaser snippet at the
beginning you know where they set up I
don't know like I mean the mythology of
it all you know so things like that and
then they start we set something up or
with shows you know like lost uh where
this world of the island happens and
then
several episodes later things start
happening lost actually for me
it kind of like
threw me off when in season one kind of
like the bear appeared in like I don't
know episode eight or nine or something
like I don't remember exactly what
episode but like the show turned a
little more Fantastical and that wasn't
set up in the first handful of episodes
and that kind of threw me off because I
was not expecting that I was like oh
you're changing the rules than me so
late into the show that
I I can't connect with it anymore so you
need to be careful with how you set
things up more than your reader or
viewer might be turned off from that
world
so if there's magic or any kind of
Underworld or or a crossing over
mediumship or whatever it should be
established right away so that we're not
surprised by it exactly the mythology
you know all of that kind of needs to be
there so we know and it doesn't have to
be necessarily obviously magic or things
like that but for example if the world
of your story is a greedy cop show set
it up like that from the start you know
don't just then introduce something else
or if they're all good cops you know
like we need to understand what the show
is about and what the Dynamics are and
how
things work within that world like for
example Sons of Anarchy it's all about
family and the life of gangs you know
and by gangs so we understand from the
beginning and that's a show that's very
heavy on the world because it needs to
introduce this world that we haven't
seen on TV probably before the show came
out you know then the spin-off happened
with Mayans you know but Sons of Anarchy
was original and that we hadn't really
seen that world on television but there
was a lot of World building and there
was nothing magical or rules like that
but the rules were about how the gang
operated and those rules were
established from the very beginning